[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and let me once again
welcome my co-host chuck knight jack hey
neil what's happening all right a
professional stand-up comedian and in in
your current resume we have to now call
you an actor you've been acting and
stuff lately
yes yes i'm acting like a stand-up
comedian okay
it's working out well
we'll see how that goes
and of course gary o'reilly gary dude hi
neil
coming to us today actually from the uk
visiting mom that is so sweet yep
yeah we are mom's kitchen and she
stuffed you in the kitchen that's the
best yeah i've been banished
do those dishes boy
i was going to say take a hint and clean
something while you clean so get
make yourself useful
so today we're going to talk about
uh stopping the clock
of age with regard to sports performance
and this a whole field i mean just think
about that i mean i know everybody
thinks about can i live forever but um
the ones who can really monetize that
are athletes and i got a list here i
just you know tom brady is now 44.
doesn't count doesn't get down okay he's
a machine okay yeah he sold his soul he
sold himself to the devil
he sold assault to the devil okay
you got extra information there right
bargains bargains with satan do not
count
as
you know medical marvels
okay
um yeah okay we'll we'll ignore the
satan deals okay on this carmelo anthony
is 37 yeah and
lebron james is 36 yep you know these
are old-timers in their professions
right
and a 36 soccer star chris
cristiano ronaldo also
36 how are you running up and down the
field like that if you're 36 i remember
when i was 26 versus 36 36 is really
different than when you're in your 20s
so we want to know are they outliers are
they you know or they something that we
could possibly uh emulate either with
hard work or hard medicine or some kind
of training that we don't yet know about
so we've got an expert for this okay
we got
kevin stone kevin stone welcome to star
talk thank you good morning returning
our returning champion a return uh yes
yes a friend of w if you've been on at
least once before we now call you a
friend of star talk uh so you're a world
renowned i
say this right biologic joint
replacement surgeon is that a fair
thing to call you that's a fair slice of
it
oh slice okay use the word slice wow
[Laughter]
but more interesting for me and more
important for the show is you are
chairman of the stone foundation and if
you're a
scientist surgeon physician you're all
of these things
coming together bringing your your broad
expertise on this subject coming
together to help patients sort of
bounce back and extend
their their you know delay their
expiration date for whatever it is
they're doing in their sport and more
recently just at the end of last year um
in 2021 you're author of a new book play
forever
which is destined for the best seller
list because that's what we all want to
do so let's let's let's get this party
started and
how much does medicine know i would lead
off i know chuck and gary you got a lot
of questions how much does medicine know
today
to for any of us to believe that it
could have any influence on our
longevity because it's one thing to live
for a long time it's another thing to be
in your prime for a long time and those
are not the same thing
it's a great point and the answer is we
know a lot about what doesn't work
and so the first part of that is that
first of all 36 today
is or a good way to say it is you know
36 is the new 26. if you started
out on the right foot
if you're now an older athlete and you
weren't taking great care of yourself
all the way along
then you've got a whole other set of
things to think about about how do you
extend your playing time
so we know a lot about how to do that
now but we really know a lot about what
doesn't work too
yeah well okay so there's some obvious
things we think don't work like drugs
and alcohol yeah yeah
yet
mick jagger is turning 80 soon all right
and i don't know that he and his and his
teammates on stage were any poster
children for a model diet or a model
lifestyle so
if he can do this at 80 what do we need
you for
sorry
so what you need me for is to point out
what worked for me and what doesn't work
for others and one of the things that
you notice that works for him is he has
this tremendous amount of exuberance
and an optimistic approach and
exuberance is a big part of health
interesting
i mean are you saying but but i mean
there are a lot of people who feel like
what you just said is
a lot of this is
literally in your head
could that be the case is that what
you're saying
kevin so if you took mick jagger's
lifestyle and put it into somebody who
was depressed or somebody who wasn't
enthusiastic somebody who was just going
along in life
i don't think you'd have a mick jagger
if you took mick jagger's lifestyle and
put it into somebody who's exuberant let
me give you an example a patient who
goes into surgery when i'm taking a
patient in surgery
if they have a smile on their face
they have a better outcome
they influence the surgeon they
influence the anesthesiologist they
influence the nurses in recovery they
influence their rehab team
they do better what if i pay you more
money
[Laughter]
so
so i think positive outlook you know no
one's going to argue that that doesn't
help and isn't good for things
but
um
it's but that feels kind of new-agey not
that that's a bad thing but you know
when i turn to medical experts i want to
hear what's going on with my dna i want
to hear what what chemicals are
happening i want to hear uh what you
know which which cells are dying at what
rate and i don't think they care how i
think or feel do they actually they
really do so you know there's a whole
field of genetics but there's also a
whole field of epi genetics and those
that's how your environment in part
influences your genetic expression
and so yes if you're a little new agey
and you're happy and you're optimistic
and you're going into things with a
great attitude you do have better
genetics and you do have better health
and one other thing about that is that
the other side to the mindset as you
were saying it's all in your head the
other side of the mindset is so many of
the injuries i see in athletes of all
ages are mental errors
their mind wasn't in the game they were
thinking about their girlfriend they're
on their cell phone they're skiing fast
and thinking about something else they
actually in that moment were not in the
game and that's where we see the errors
occur
all right doctor here wow if i had as a
professional athlete if i got an injured
injury or i needed to face surgery as a
result of something i'm really not a
happy past person it's difficult for me
to crack a smile knowing i've lost my
place in the team i'm going to be out
next week's x months
but
you're you are angry you're on a good
day i'm pissed off right
this is how it is and but you're saying
we have to look at this it's a different
class as an opportunity yeah look at
this as an opportunity
for me to
come back even better rather than the
tragedy i've got going off in my head as
of this injury exactly right and so if i
can bond with you
talking with you before we go into
surgery if you need surgery if i can
convince you yeah use that injury as an
excuse as an opportunity to become as we
say fitter faster and stronger than
you've been in years
then you're going to turn that injury
into something that helps you and so
listen any pro athlete coming into our
clinic is coming in with his rehab team
his nutrition team his massage therapist
his site counselor is his coach
why not treat yourself to the same set
of skills same set of resources or at
least the same set of techniques because
they're so available and why not take
even if your main sport is going for a
walk in the mall
let's use that as a goal to be able to
go for a walk without having pain but if
your sport is to come back to playing
football
either european football or american
football why don't we use that injury
and the best athletes do this all the
time they'll use that injury to come
back better than they were before so do
we all have to be elite athletes we all
have to have the elite athlete mentality
but everybody's got yourself that way
treat yourself like a pro athlete would
not everybody can doctor well so what
we're trying to teach in this book and
what we're trying to teach to our
patients and what we're trying to spread
the word about is that the resources
online the resources from your doctors
your therapists your trainers your
health they're there you just have to
access them you just have to switch that
switch in your own mind and say i can do
this i can turn this negative into a
positive
so it really does as neil brought up
before it really does affect your
biology it affects how you heal it
affects how fast you heal it affects how
all your teammates and your therapists
and everybody else view you and so if
you can turn that injury into that
opportunity you'll do so well so part of
our mission here in the book play
forever
is how do you drop dead 100 play in the
sport you love
the way you do that is looking at every
little bump in the road
as an opportunity to do better to become
fitter faster and stronger okay so let
me ask this then
if if you're looking at it from a
psychological standpoint
is it possible to overcome
some of the
bad habits that a lot of people have
let's say for instance
look at what sugar does to the body
sugar causes inflammation and the
inflammation has a reaction that is
damaging
so
i can't
like positive think my way out of that
right
but you can positive think your way to a
healthier nutrition a healthier diet you
can take the tom brady approach you can
take the approach that so many athletes
who are acting as role models for all of
us and say listen if i feed myself if i
fuel my body the way i'd want to fuel my
engine of a car of a race car then my
body will perform that way and if i fuel
my body poorly the body will perform
poorly yeah but kevin i think what i
came to learn
is and i i came to this revelation maybe
it was obvious to everyone else but i
had to figure it out on my own
uh when you look at
you look at um
who's our nine gold medal swimmer um
we're 10. michael phelps look at michael
phelps and he's always got the body for
a swimmer well he's in the water six
hours a day right so
all right that's a that's a factor in
this or however many hours the man
trains then i realized that what will
distinguish
elite athletes from the rest of us
is the
is the is the
the boundless
urge
to
work on their body and their performance
we had lindsey vaughn as a guest
oh my gosh you hear her she she fell one
time going down thinking twisted
something she was helicoptered away and
all she could think of was getting back
on the slopes not omg my gosh oh my dem
i hurt well i was
that [ __ ] that was not in her thoughts
and the next day she was back skiing and
so so it was
we this is not a common way to think
about our bodies and ourselves and so
what you're saying
is true and is common but it seems to be
only in this this very selected set of
people whose minds
uh have this
can reach these levels of access to
their own performance that the rest of
us can't
but you can you don't need to perform at
an olympic level to be healthy and fit
and play forever you just need to play
every day
you just need to say every day i'm going
to play my sport work out do something
exercise wise for my mind and my body
and if you do that every day neil you
become addicted to the good pheromones
and hormones and testosterone and
adrenaline that you feel when you get to
that point of exercise when you know
you've exhausted yourself or tired
yourself
your level doesn't have to be olympic
your level has to be just a little
better than neil is today it's just my
whatever is beyond what i am a little
whatever that is that's why
that's why you never watch tv or read a
book when you're working out because if
you do you're losing half the point of
working out half the benefit you need to
hear your heart rate feel where you're
breathing know where your muscles are
tired and go just a little bit beyond
that every day and if you do you'll
quickly become addicted the way lindsey
vaughn
all right so doctor here's my here's my
thought process are we going to see
players in the future
maybe
chuck's favorite tom brady maybe lebron
maybe someone coming through
who have 30-plus year careers go into
their 50s
is i mean
we always know the desire is there it
good it got us there in the first place
what changes is our physicality
would you say we overcome
i have many 70 year olds now who are
running marathons running centuries they
run their age and they are performing at
levels you've never dreamed of before
and in part is the mind and part is the
physicality their ability to have
developed themselves over the years
many of my top athletic women
did not become runners and athletes
until they were in their 40s
so they shifted to that maturity
that permitted them to listen to
themselves and push their bodies a
little bit fast
all right like kevin we got to take a
break but when we come back we're going
to find out what might be actually
happening in kevin stone's lab ooh when
star talk sports edition returns
so we're back star talks sports edition
and i'm here with our guest dr kevin
stone who's head of the stone foundation
did i say that right
stone clinic in the stone research
foundation yeah the stone clinic and the
stone refrigerator what a coincidence it
has this exactly
wow
two eponymous organizations i wonder
who's behind that
hmm
and there's no d
no d no stoned right just
uh
and of course we've got chuck and gary
here uh we in our first segment we just
talked about what effect the mind would
have on your body and your performance
but i want to sort of shift
re-steer that now and talk about what
you actually do with people physically i
mean you're a surgeon and you specialize
in joints these are usually the things
that first go out
that first fail in any kind of
attempt to do things a long time and so
uh you know the first thing that comes
to mind is arthritis like what do you
have to say about that because that sort
of arises late typically later in
people's lives but also what about drugs
that you might give people that would
rebuild their muscles or their bones or
whatever else
what what physically do you do
so what we're doing now that's so
different from what people heard about
before is that every time someone
injures the key tissues just focused on
the knees so their meniscus cartilage or
their atl
we repair or replace those tissues we
replace the meniscus if it's injured and
a surgeon takes it out so we've learned
that if you take the key tissues out of
the joint
you develop arthritis so so many of us
on this call so many of the listeners
have injured their knee in high school
or college the surgeon went in they took
out the meniscus they said come back and
talk to us when you develop arthritis
years from now or you need your knee
replacement
so what we've changed is now it's come
back immediately and put the meniscus
back in the joint regrow the articular
cartilage that we thought we couldn't
regrow and we've learned now how to
regrow it and we do that both for young
athletes
and we do that for people who already
have arthritis
and so arthritis used to be go home and
rest your knee and wait for your joint
replacement
now arthritis is come in let's replace
or regrow the tissues let's lubricate
the joints let's add growth factors and
recruit your body's own stem cells let's
do all these things that do regeneration
of tissue
rather than taking it out and waiting
for your joint replacement okay sure but
does that bring you back better than you
were when you when you hobbled into your
clinic oh who cares
that's so cool
i would do it just to do it
it certainly brings you back better if
you've been limping around for years or
cutting back on all your sports because
it hurt you stopped running because your
joints get stiff and more painful
so what we're trying to do is restore
the biology of people's joints so we can
then work with them physically to train
and exercise and play the sports they
want
now what do you do if what do you do if
that um
degradation and deterioration is due to
another problem outside of just wear and
tear
or
you know use
like what um for instance if i have some
type of autoimmune disorder that causes
um a deterioration of my joints or
causes inflammation in my joints which
and then turns into deterioration
so it's a great question so there's
basically two major groups of arthritis
there's the inflammatory arthritis and
that's the rheumatoid infections
autoimmune diseases lyme disease
that's one group of patients that are
not the patients that we're treating
with joint replacement tissue issues in
injection
the group that we're treating are the
post traumatic arthritis and the
osteoarthritis that group is usually
athletes or people have injured their
knee or had or picked their parents
poorly and they got the genetics of
osteoarthritis
yeah so doctor uh there is another
technique that's i don't know if it's
still around it used to be called micro
fracturing
right and i know a number of basketball
players have had it but i'm not i mean
it's not something i've experienced it's
just something i'm aware of but
what are we doing this is obvious as a
title says they're micro fractures so
how are we doing this does this work
so micro fracturing taught us all a lot
that if you bloody a dead arthritic area
in a joint you can get the marrow cells
that have all these progenitor and
growth cells in them to stimulate a
repair process
but unfortunately in micro fracture the
repair process led to scar tissue
but we learned from that that you can
stimulate a healing response so now we
add something called a paste graft or a
mixture of articular cartilage and
cancellous bone to that micro fracture
or or a super micro fracture where we
stimulate a much bigger response in the
joint and then we add growth factors to
it to stimulate full healing back to a
healthier kind of cartilage repair what
does the word articular mean as you used
it thanks so in the joint you've got two
types of cartilage so when you crack
open the chicken wing that white shiny
that's articular cartilage
and when you get arthritis it's wearing
of that articular cartilage down to the
bone okay so that articular cartilage is
that white shiny surface that we're
trying to regrow so this this process
when you apply the the regenerative
paste if i can call it that is is that
an anabolic therapy because isn't
testosterone good for
healing fractures but we don't maybe
have enough of it in our own bodies to
to achieve the process fully so when we
think about anabolics we're thinking
past testosterone now so we're trying to
stimulate the body's own natural
stimulation or anabolic
healing process as opposed to catabolic
so if you have arthritis
you have degradative enzymes in the
joint that are breaking down your
tissues
and we want to shift that to an anabolic
or positive set of growth factors and
cells that are building up your tissues
and so not testosterone although we are
studying testosterone in order to
prevent muscle atrophy after injury
but generally when we're talking about
regenerative therapies rebuilding
people's joints biologically we're
talking about adding tissues and adding
recruitment factors that recruit your
body's own stem cells and stem cell
derived repair cells to the site of
injury and that's the most exciting part
of this because each of you sitting here
even as
um
mature as neil have billions of stem
cells in their body
young people have more
but everybody has them
wait kevin i have to correct you
i have billions and billions billions
and billions
neil is what he was studying all these
years in astrophysics had he just looked
inside he would have found the same
number of billions of interesting
constellations of cells that is where
we're studying today and trying to
recruit those supernovas to your own
injury that's what this whole field is
about now so do these stem cells
uh do our stem cells age like other
cells do they become less effective as
you get older
in fact they do not uh-huh to a stem
cell is that it regenerates itself and
so when we go recruit your body's stem
cells what happens is we're sending
these factors out
they cause the stem cell that lives in
the walls of vessels
to release divide into two one is a
daughter cell exactly like the mother
and the other is a progeny or a
progenitor cell that rushes to the site
of injury and starts doing its work
wow so here doctor here's a thought and
i've experienced this through teammates
back as a player and then through my own
self
athletes don't recover at the same speed
and sometimes as you get older your your
recovery time
for an injury you would have had in your
early 20s is maybe twice as long why if
we're regenerating our stem cells why
aren't we recovering at the same pace
each time
so it's a great question a couple of
things around that number one as you get
older you do have fewer cells even
though you have still have billions of
them number two your
chemistry of your tissue and biology of
your tissues is not the same as you age
the makeup of the tissue is different
and then number three if you ask
yourself the question which all our
athletes ask
doc why does it take a year to come back
from my acl injury or my achilles rub
these tissues that need to regrow and
hey doc isn't there something you can
just add to accelerate that healing
process and so all of the research that
we're doing at stone research foundation
in san francisco is around which factors
should you give which injury so clearly
an arthritic knee should get different
factors than an acl injured knee or an
achilles rupture and we're getting very
targeted now about
identifying which cells will respond to
which factors if i'm an elite athlete
into my 50s and then i go bonkers and
and refuse to leave and i'm in my 60s
what body parts would you imagine i'm
actually am i a cyborg by then have you
replaced most of my body parts
yeah wait wait wait let's wait let's
unpack that so so kevin
when do when do you have to actually
start replacing body parts versus
encouraging the body to heal itself at
some point you say look we you need a
new knee or you need a new hip we need a
new shoulder right at some point you're
doing that i presume right
so there's two parts to that
number one you can run forever
as long as you don't get hurt
so it's injury or bad genes picking your
parents poorly that can develop
arthritis but if you have a healthy
joint you can run on it forever the
joint is designed to last that's number
one number two eighty percent of the
people who have been told they need to
have a knee replacement
don't
there's an alternative for them and an
alternative could be either a biologic
replacement putting tissue back in
or a partial knee replacement where you
just resurface one part of the knee
or nowadays if we have to do a full
replacement we use a robot and we you
and we avoid cement because of the
precision of the robot so that we can
get these people back to playing the
sports they love even if they've had a
joint replacement you're saying the
robot is the surgeon yeah the robot
makes the surgeon me
much more precise than i could ever be
so let me ask you this then if if if a
healthy joint
can last forever
what happens during an injury that makes
it so that that joint now
is so compromised that it can't last
forever so remember we talked about that
white shiny surface in the chicken wing
that white shiny surface is five times
as slick as ice on ice if it's not
injured
once you injure it you create a rough
spot in it and you've changed the entire
properties of that articular cartilage
and it starts off the wearing away
process so if you don't get injured and
you've got some good genes you can go
for her
wow
so getting back to gary's point if gary
wants to keep playing soccer in his 50s
and 60s and into his 70s
at what point
is is
have you touched every one of his joints
you're saying if he doesn't get injured
his joints are still working just fine
that's what you heard
okay all right so gary you're not cyborg
right you're just gary
yeah
with some seriously injured joints
[Laughter]
no i got a feeling with gary right now
uh dr stone would have to stand above
him uh while he raises them up to
lightning and go it's alive
it's just about right
kevin have you seen there's a youtube
video of centogenarians racing 100 meter
dash
have you ever seen this i haven't seen
that video it's very interesting
you know they're not
going real fast but they're putting it
all out something that we should answer
though is there's no limit to the age at
which you can either have a tissue
repaired or a tissue replaced and i
think you're asking that earlier if
you're 70 and you come into my clinic
and say hey doc i'm still running i want
to keep running i'm not ready for a
joint replacement i really would like
you to take a shock absorber back in my
knee and give me a few more years
there's no reason why we can't do that
as long as there's still joint space if
they come in too late in this bone on
bone then we have to shift you're
capping it with a metal cap
it's like breaks it's like when you get
your brakes fixed
you know if you go if you go in they're
like oh man i'm sorry that's metal on
metal
that we could do for you buddy we gotta
we gotta replace the pads and the rotors
the pads
yeah i'm sorry
it's a perfect analogy
plus every time you mention lubricant to
the joints all i could think of is the
tin man and
in the wizard of oz
so do you um do you have a list of
athletes that is in your sort of your
honor roll for those who you've helped
we do
okay
that was awesome
okay he was like
and my doctor patient confidentiality
says that i can't tell you who they are
let me ask you this doctor so you we're
talking a lot about knees here and you
know knees and hips which are you know
common problem areas but what about
these areas where we're looking at like
tendons
so where you got you know something soft
going to the bone itself uh what are you
able to do for stuff like that because
that's another area of injury that
happens to a lot of people athletes and
otherwise right it brings up a great
point so in the past when you came in
with a tennis elbow or a sore achilles
tendon the doc would jam some cortisone
into those tissues and send you on your
way and unfortunately often
when you went on your way you ruptured
that tissue because the cortisone shuts
down the healing response and inhibits
cell metabolism
so today when you come in we inject
growth factors usually taken from your
own blood called prp
and
soon some other types of factors as well
because just as we talked about earlier
we want to recruit your body's healing
response augment it accelerate it at
that spot of degeneration or sometimes
inflammation so so that's the exact
opposite of putting in
uh steroids exactly they're exactly
opposite exactly steroids have almost
gone away from our practice wow
all right we got to take a quick break
but when we come back we're going to ask
dr stone about the future of all of this
what can we expect in 5 10 20 50 years
and
will we all be living forever one day
and what does that even mean
star talk sports edition we'll be right
back
we're back star talk sports edition dr
kevin stone
an expert in making you
live longer better i guess if i
characterize that and we got of course
chuck and gary and kevin where where can
we find you on the internet
so at stoneclinic.com
uh and stoneresearch.org
excellent and we can find your book
right uh your book was just released
play forever so all very good in this
segment we want to just talk about the
future of
the future implications of your work not
only for those who you're treating now
but you know the future kevin stone or
descendants of your of your
points of views and philosophies uh in
this on this landscape but let me lead
off with a question before i hand back
to chuck and gary
in your book you you you play forever
you list
five reasons to avoid space travel
and other than the rocket might blow up
i'll give you one of those
is that one of them i don't know
that would that would be a reason to
avoid space travel but what else might
you um what else have you put in that
list
yeah so our concerns about space travel
are many of course but
excess radiation loss of gravity mental
status are all the first three that pop
up in people's conversations and so
um we are really encouraging people to
focus on what they can do while here on
earth and how to make earth better
because i think space travel will be
predominantly for robots
wow and now is there any okay wait
that's the end of this interview
i'm done
no
i have one rebuttal just one the others
i'm i'm cool with it if we the day we
designed rotating space stations there's
no concern for for loss of uh bone mass
or anything else that has so preoccupied
the medical community about what happens
when you're in zero g for so long you
rotate the space station you're in one g
for as long as you want and so that that
whole problem goes away radiation we're
still working on that we've got top
people thinking that through and yeah
we've got problems on earth um
no bout to doubt it
but
um who are we to say or to think that
the solutions to those problems would
not be found
uh exploring the rest of the universe
that's all i'll put that out there but
anyhow let's go let's go into the future
of this and gary you're always thinking
about ai so what yeah what's your ai
question here
can ai will ai be able to unlock the
biologic story
and then sort of allow us and enlighten
us to be able to see the areas of which
we can address aging we can address
certain elements that have been beyond
our graphs so far
absolutely yes
so in your in the pocket of your doctor
is a high-powered computer otherwise
known as an iphone
and on that iphone
you can load the most potent artificial
intelligence programs
that help everyone make a better
diagnosis and a better decision for the
patient in the same way that if you take
a photograph of your iphone today
it makes you look like ansel adams you
know a brilliant perfect photograph the
ai on that camera has made all of their
cameras obsolete
and so the ai in the pocket of the
doctor
will make the doctor's decision making
so much better where are we going to go
where where for in your field right
where would you like ai
to address its gaze and find you
solutions specifically in the
treatment
prevention and cure of arthritis
so as we like to say cancer may kill you
but arthritis ruins your life
and so i think we can help so many
people so many athletes so many of all
of our friends and parents and children
if we can just address and focus on
solving arthritis which all of our
research shows is totally solvable
yeah
can i ask you this about arthritis i had
a
piano teacher who had
arthritis and continued to play
although his hands were mangled and i by
that i mean they looked like they had
drawn up into themselves
and he did not he couldn't bend the
joints any longer but he adapted his
hands to play
uh a different way
what is it that's going on with
arthritis that causes that effect of
like the
the joints drawing into themselves and
taking this calcified
kind of state
so the destruction of the articular
cartilage the bearing surface is the
beginning but following that this the
lining of the joint becomes contracted
and the muscles and tendons around it
become shortened and so that you can no
longer extend that joint
so a big part of arthritis prevention is
making sure that you maintain your
flexibility
so all of us who are
active in fitness training
focus now more on mobility first
and strength second because without
mobility you don't have the ability to
perform to to use that strength in the
most optimal way back to neil's point
i'm a huge fan of space exploration
because i think that we learn so much
from environments that challenge us in
ways that our local environments don't
in the same way that we learn so much
about biology from the arthritic joint
we learn so much about healing from the
injured athlete especially the injured
athlete and almost all of my injured pro
athletes chief
meaning
i tell them to do something and they do
much more without telling me and then i
learned from them
i learned from them what works because
they push the limits past what i thought
could work it's the same thing that
happens in space we learn from the
people in the in the instruments that go
to space
what are the limits of our design of our
knowledge of our experience on earth so
space is a huge teacher for us to be
able to excel
i just my bias is that i think space
will be predominantly dominated by
robots rather than people because we are
so fragile
so you more than once have mentioned uh
choosing your parents
well right and so the the future version
of that is gene editing isn't it where
i can't choose my parents but i can i
can alter my
i can edit them out
edit them out
damn chuck why you gotta be so negative
sorry mom gotta photoshop you out of
this
you left all this bad stuff in my dna
exactly
so that that's the equivalent to this
isn't it
in a nicer way the way we say it is that
some of the genes that your parents
passed on to you
you can do things to stop the expression
of those genes so that they don't
destroy your life or your joints or your
imagination so in so many ways now we've
learned to affect your mind we've
learned how to affect your body we've
learned how to affect how you express
things and so we know that when you take
a simple supplement like glucosamine
which we all have been exposed to
it not only makes you feel less stiff
and it acts as a
precursor to the building of the
lubricant and the joint hyaluronic acid
but it affects how the genes express
that lubricant and so our nutrition
affects our genetic expression and it
affects our epigenetics how our genes
are expressed as well so even though
neil was going down the line of hey will
we be doing uh draconian neo uh
draconian editing of our children
yes we do but we do it in ways that are
natural that are healthy that are
inspiring you don't need to go in and
edit out their genes to edit out their
compression
so doctor
where are we going to go with
nanotechnology what do you expect
that to be with humans in the future
so we have an experiment going on right
now
using nanoparticles of copper
that we add to cells in tissue culture
to see if we can make the cells produce
more extracellular matrix meaning
behave stronger and and start the
healing response
so the ability to use extremely small
particles to develop to deliver
stimulants
is a wide open field that we think will
make a lot of progress in
wow all right so take that forward
you've talked about robots in space but
what are our surgical robots going to
look like in the future are they are
they going to
be able to do things
that we can't quite dream of right now
or we've pretty good pretty much got an
idea of what they can do
oh i think we're we're only in the very
beginning um i learned and when i picked
up a surgical robot about eight years
ago to make my partial and total joints
replacements better i learned very
quickly that it was far more precise
than i could ever be
and so my precision has increased
dramatically and i think going forward
my interaction with robotic technology
will make my decision making and my
surgical precision better
so i think right now it's helping
technically
but going forward it'll help
in with the ai enabled robots to help
diagnostically and in decision making
yeah but kevin it's one thing for the
robot to make you better but i think in
the real future we'll have robots that
can do things
that
you wouldn't even have attempted
isn't that correct i mean just
i i i don't know what
uh what would be an example
an example would be like going instead
of putting in a stent going in and
actually cleaning out an artery like
a tool that small that could go in
uh
local
identify a blockage remove it
and move on yeah exactly so it'll be
it'll be kind of tools that
would perform operations that were
undoable in a previous time rather than
just simply making you better at what
you were already going to do are you
implying that there's something that i
can't do
he wants job security
so all right um while we're here looking
forwards
we're at a certain point with stem cell
knowledge are we going to take that a
lot further or are we kind of pushing
as far as we think we can go right now
oh we're only in the very beginning
because as i mentioned to you you have
billions of stem cells and how we induce
them and how we get the right cells to
the right spot how we induce the cell
that goes to that spot to do what we
want it to do how we get healing to
occur faster so that acl injured athlete
doesn't have to wait a year these are
all spaces that we're experimenting with
now we have an interesting model called
the lab on a chip where we can take the
cells of the patient put it on a slide
the way you used to put it on a
microscopic slide in your high school
biology and on that slide we have tons
of little micro vesicle vessels there or
portals there so that we can add
different
cell behaviors different growth factors
to those cells and see what happens
so we're taking the lab on a chip model
the stem cell model the growth factor
model and testing it individually for
each patient
and so this field of called
microfluidics and lab on a chip is a
space that we're using to push forward
the entire healing process information
that we wish we knew more about
but kevin this feels very different from
the conversations people are having
about living forever
right you're talking about just
the absence of pain and joints as we get
older so you can still do stuff but that
doesn't stop you from dying
doesn't it unless you've got some other
plan in your lab
no and the the answer is that number one
your relatives
your government
nobody wants you to live forever they
can't afford you neil yeah
what they want only you that wants that
what they want and what what we're
trying to do is help you drop dead at
100 playing the sport you love so we
want to help you be live an active
healthy fulfilled enthusiastic lifestyle
all the way to the very end and if we
can do that we feel like we've
contributed much more to you than just
prolonging a life
not only that the entire health care
system that is supporting 80 year olds
and up that would be completely
transformed in the face of what you're
talking about yeah
oh dramat dramatically reduces the cost
you said to me a couple of years ago doc
uh what we know now is not good enough
we're here we're in the beginning of
nine of 19 yes gary 2022
what we know
now is it good enough have we made the
serious progress you would have expected
let me answer that and say what we know
now is how little we know
wow thanks
answer that one yeah your next question
is honey where were you last night what
i know is that i don't know
[Laughter]
all right so
chuck something chuck touched on earlier
in in this show was about
ligaments and you know we've we've
harvested animal parts to
replace
human tissues
in the future
are we going to kind of 3d print our own
or is the body going to reject that sort
of material
it's a great question what we're going
to do is and what we've started doing is
3d printing the regeneration templates
for your body to grow into since we now
are getting better and better at
stimulating your body to regrow often it
doesn't have the template or the rose
trellis to gr grow out over
but if we give it that template the body
can regrow tissues that we used to think
if you put that include meniscus and
articular cartilage and ligament so a
big part of the 3d printing part is not
to replicate exactly what evolution is
you know spent millions of years
developing
it's to replicate a trellis a stimulant
for the body to grow through so the
salamander can regrow its tail without
that
that trellis a child can regrow the tip
of its finger without it but you seem to
lose that as you grow older even though
you have the genetics inside you that
know how to do it and so what we're
learning now is if we give it that
template if we then stimulate those
cells we can get the body to regrow a
number of tissues we didn't think were
possible
wow
so now with that type of
will we ever speaking of the salamander
will we ever have the ability
to
regenerate that which was never
generated for instance some people have
congenital problems where they're born
without an arm or whatever would we be
able to then program cells to go in
and then
grow where that arm was not
it's not out of the question it's
outside of the field of what i'm doing
now but it's not out of the question and
where that applies right away it's
clearly in the spinal cord where people
have injuries or defects there and
there's been tremendous progress in
stimulating neurons to grow in cells to
grow that previously we thought you just
couldn't do including brain tissue liver
tissue heart tissue all the tissues in
the past that we used to think once
you're injured you're done
that's really not the case and it's
likely going forward that we'll be
regrowing these tissues that we didn't
think we could guys we got to land this
plane uh listen uh dr stone it's been
great to have you back on star talk this
is really interesting frontier stuff
always and we love talking about that on
this show and uh if you can keep us
plugged in delighted about your new book
and tell us that who published that and
where we can find it so you find it on
amazon play forever and i hope that it
inspires you and your listeners to stay
active and play the sports they love and
not let anything get in the way
and and drop dead the day after 100.
that's right playing the sport you left
okay
all right we'll make we will make sure
that so guys uh that's it that's all the
time we have uh chuck gary always good
to have you there as my co-host
and kevin we will find you again because
this topic is not going to go away and
as we as more and more athletes ascend
into their twilight years but it's
actually the dawn years
in your reckoning of time so
this has been star talk sports edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking out
[Music]
you